ذخائر تحتوي على يورانيوم منظف ستسلمها
واشنطن في اطار دفعه جديده من المساعدات
العسكريه بقيمه 175 مليون دولار هذا ما
اعلنه البنتاجون بالتزامن مع زياره وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي انتون بلينكن الى زياره
اظهر خلالها التزام الولايات المتحده
الثابت بسياده اوكرانيا معلنا عن مساعده
لها بقيمه اكثر من مليار دولار الرئيس
الاوكراني اعرب عن امتنانه للولايات
المتحده وحذر من شتاء صعب ينتظر اوكرانيا
نشكر مساعدتكم لنا في قطاع الطاقه هناك
شتاء صعب ينتظرنا لكننا سعداء لاننا لسنا
لوحدنا خلال هذا الشتاء
زياره بلنكا الى كيف تاتي مع دخول الهجوم
المضاد الذي تشنه اوكرانيا على القوات
الروسيه شهره الرابع والذي قال انه يرى
فيه تقدما مشجعا للغايه
اعلم انكم كنتم على الخط الامامي ونتطلع
الى سماع تقييمكم وبالتاكيد نرى التقدم
الكبير الذي تم احرازه في الهجوم المضاد
وهو امر مشجع للغايه
من جهته اتهم الكرملين الولايات المتحده
بابقاء اوكرانيا في حاله حرب
نسمع تصريحات متكرره تفيد بانهم يعتزمون
مواصله مساعده كييف مهما طال الامر اي
سيواصلون دعم اوكرانيا وشن الحرب حتى اخر
اوكراني هذا تصورنا وهذا لن يؤثر على مسار
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه
وكانت الولايات المتحده في طليعه الدول
التي قدمت الدعم لاوكرانيا حيث تعهدت
بتقديم مساعدات عسكريه تزيد قيمتها عن 43
مليار دولار منذ شنه موسكو غزوها في شبات
فبراير عام 2022